- [Man] Good to see you, man.
- [Gary] Good to see you. How are you?
- I'm good man it's Big Baby
- What's up champ?
- [Ronald] How you doing, brother?
- Good to see you, man.
It's been a pleasure.
- What's going on?
- What's up?
- Mike.
- Mike, how are you?
- [Behind Camera] You guys get comfy.
- Now where is my guy?
How are you man?
- I'm good, man good.
Thanks for having me.
- Good, man.
I was watching,
I'm a big fight fan,
I was watching a fight
of yours one or two back,
and just went heavy into Google,
and reading all about you,
so when this came through,
I was like, yes.
You know, just so busy
these days trying to
manage all my time,
but as soon as I saw this,
I was like let's do it for sure.
I'm excited for you, man.
I'm excited about the next chapter, man.
- Appreciate it.
- It's about to get interesting for you.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Cause I really follow this sport.
So over the next 18 months
it's all gonna play out.
So it's gonna be interesting.
That under-card exposure was...
That exposure you got that week before...
Were you on the under-card?
No it was the week before Ortiz...
It was a month before, right?
- Correct, correct right.
- And Barclay, right?
That was good timing.
I was watching, like I've
been watching from afar,
the awareness of you building up.
And I feel like that last fight
was the one that people are like,
"Okay, that guy's in the mix now.
Whoever wins in those two guys,"
like, you know?
- Correct.
- I feel like you're
right on the cusp now.
- [Man] Yeah, it's interesting.
- Is that the way you guys feel too?
- [Man] Yes, totally.
He's there.
But also he keeps winning the fights.
- What's that?
Oh you mean people
actually wanting to fight?
- [Man] He's looking for
guys to fight right now
I know, who the fuck wants to fight you?
- [Man] He doesn't have the name yet
to make it worthwhile for someone.
- 100 percent.
- [Man] It's too scary to
take a risk without a name.
- So it's like...
- When'd you get into the fight game?
For real?
- 14.
- 14 years old, kickboxing.
- Why'd it happen?
Oh, kickboxing.
- [Man] He's 22 and
two as a pro kickboxer.
Only losing to Mirko Cro Cop who's
one of the best of all time.
- And those two fights I know I won.
(laughing)
- I love fighters, man.
Fighters have never lost.
- I hit him in the knee and
the referee says low blow.
It was a good fight.
- Why'd you transition?
You thought the cultural opportunity,
you were getting bored, money?
- I always loved martial arts fighting,
but you know the money,
I was gonna be a boxer
'cause the kickboxing
kinda been the forefront of
where I got my start in from.
And then when I finally, I got suspended,
I didn't get into a fight
with one of the senseis.
So I didn't wanna sit
home and not do nothing,
got into the boxing.
And we just never left after that.
- That was it.
Just took over.
- Fucking love it.
So who are you?
- [Man] I'm just a friend.
Entrepreneur?
- I'm an entrepreneur.
I own a PR business, a modern PR business.
Meaning we get shit done.
And I introduced you to
Arby Marcus last year.
I have a lot of people in my life
and they'll see that I know you
and everybody wants to know you.
Everybody wants this 15
minutes with Gary Vee.
They wanna pick your brain.
- So humbling.
It's the best, 'cause
I wanna meet you too.
I was like yes.
Honestly, it's the best.
It's the best, the best.
Because for me when I go into this,
in like a fight mode, I go into like
I'm just gonna give 'em
everything I can give him.
Which is why people want it.
'Cause I don't want
nothing, I wanna give it.
And I like it, and it's cool and it's fun.
Especially hip-hop or boxing,
things that I really fuck with
then it's like triple fun right?
How can I help?
- [Man] People say like,
oh Anna Kournikova,
she was really fucking good,
she was the top 40 player in the world,
she was beautiful and she
focused on other things.
- She was so culturally relevant that,
I couldn't agree more.
I believe in that the most.
- [Man] So we're at a
place where we are arguably
one of the best in the entire
world at this right now,
but right now it's like,
how do we get our name,
how do Gerell get his name from
a contender to the guy that is the guy
that's making the most noise.
- I got a lot of ideas.
First of all,
boxing content culture on Instagram
is a huge opportunity for you.
If I open my explorer right
now, basketball, boxing.
I'm even sad at myself,
I'm like why are all
the pretty girls gone?
I'm I still not a dude?
It's all just boxing, you know?
That's the biggest tell
of who somebody is.
If you really wanna know
who the fuck you are,
yeah I know who you are,
you're a scum-bucket.
You could really figure
yourself out real quick.
So what do they have?
All these boxing meme accounts.
They're stuck because nobody
is Anna Kournikova'ing it.
All they got is clips.
So one of the things you
absolutely should do,
is we should map those 16
to 25 accounts and be like,
yo, access like 24/7 on those 37 accounts,
when you're not even prepping for a fight,
so you following what I'm saying?
24/7 even when you're
not prepping for a fight,
aka documenting your life this right now,
on those boxing, they need content.
There's only so many times
you can show me the fuckin'
Ricky Hatton got knocked
out by Manny Pacquiao clip.
Right?
There's only so many times
you can show Wilder swinging wide, right?
- Yeah.
So I think you should
hit up those accounts,
him 'em hard and be like
what would bring you value?
And then you gotta chop him up,
you gotta chop yourself up with like,
okay I'm gonna give this guy this story,
but that's gonna get you serious exposure
in the micro community,
comma, next,
we gotta reverse engineer you.
What else do you fuck with?
Music, what other sports,
what else do you fuck with?
It's honestly just doing what I,
like me, people know I like the Jets,
people know I like hip-hop,
like what else?
So do you understand?
- Yep.
You gotta work.
Exactly what you're doing now, you got it.
You're already on the pieces.
But now it's about where,
not overthinking it.
People overthink where the attention is
without understanding where it is.
I would give a fuck about
him way more right now
if he did 37 different interviews
with those meme accounts,
and they clipped it for one minute
where he calls out this guy,
he compares himself to that guy,
he talks about Michael Dokes in this,
he talks about Mike
Tyson's punch out in that,
he talks about fucking,
(laughing)
I'm showing you.
Listen I'm really about the sport, my guy.
You know, that's it.
You DM Riddick Bowe and be like yo,
come through, let's
chop it up for an hour,
eat some burgers, and fucking,
you see where I'm going?
- [Man] Yeah, totally.
- Hack it.
You put in the work.
- [Man] Podcast.
- Bigger commitment for right now,
that's why I'm not going with it.
I love podcasts, being
on them, doing them.
But the boxing thing's real interesting.
Boxing will never admit it, but UFC
did a lot of good for boxing.
It really did.
The contemporary nature
of what UFC and Dana White
did from a marketing standpoint
created an underbelly.
Boxing didn't do it, Haymon didn't do it.
But the culture's doing it.
- yeah
You understand?
- yeah sure
It's real fun.
I really like it.
And I really love boxing,
so it makes me happy.
I think it's just putting in work.
Putting in work.
In the boxing lane,
and then, you know it'd be great
if you could commentate on UFC,
the most knowledgeable boxer
that's legit about UFC,
but here's the point, if
he doesn't know about UFC,
or fucks with UFC, punt it.
The reason I win is
there's a lot of things I know what to do,
but I don't go there
'cause it's not authentic.
I could be much bigger if I penetrated
California, Vans, skateboard culture,
I know exactly how to do it,
I know exactly how to have
the meetings with them.
But I don't like skateboarding that much.
I like Nigel Sylvester for skateboarding,
I like when Casey does
it, I like Rodriguez,
I like Tony Hawk, I like
it, but I don't like it.
I can't bring up Michael Dokes.
You know what I mean?
I can't tell you why Julian Jackson's
the best boxer of all time.
You know what I mean?
In skateboarding.
So you need to reverse
engineer your thing.
What would you say your
biggest interests are?
- Everything fighting from
UFC, boxing, to kickboxing.
I have a lot of connections
with people in the music industry
that I've been talking to,
so I've been working with a company lately
trying to get in the music thing,
trying to get 50 Cent or Busta Rhymes,
trying to intervert the hip-hop
back into the fight game a little,
because it's kinda like that you said
before in the boxing game in America.
It's kind of like taking a faded step
because of that MMA stuff.
So I'm trying to bring some
of the rappers back into it.
- And they're coming.
They wanna come back.
- They wanna come back.
- They're following, they want it,
they like it, but it's not
like it was to your point.
- Nah.
When it's a New York fight,
especially with Mike Tyson
or somebody that's really
from the New York brand,
everybody will jump on that bandwagon,
it's a New York guy, and
we have a culture rich,
you know what I'm saying.
- 100%.
- So that's my thing,
I'm trying to find a way
just to get that one big,
that one big video to go viral.
- Can I give you, you're gonna love this,
this is gonna make so much
fucking sense to you, my guy.
That's like somebody who
thinks they're gonna win
one big punch or have one big fight.
All that work you put in the gym,
it's not, you're not gonna
make that one big video,
that one big moment.
You gotta put in the work,
you have no idea what, this is what we do.
You got it.
It's just not gonna happen.
It's like the fighters
you beat all the time,
they're looking for that one big shot.
But you have skill.
That's why they're easy for you.
You gotta make sure you
don't get hit by that shot,
but other than that it's a wrap, right?
- Right.
- That's how I think
about your content game
and what you're trying to do in culture.
You're gonna do it wrong.
You're looking for that
moment, it's gonna be this,
it's not gonna be this.
This will be good.
People are gonna watch this
and you're gonna get some
more fans and good shit,
and we'll try even harder
'cause I want you to win,
but the 27 boxing meme accounts,
the fucking, you see where I'm going?
You're gonna either put
in the work or you're not.
Collaborate, I love the
idea of collaborating
with the old boxers.
One of my favorite things in boxing
that I grew up with was there was that,
how old are you?
- [Man] 36.
- You've always liked boxing?
- [Man] Love boxing.
- Yeah, so it's a hair under you, I'm 42,
you still probably caught it.
There was that era where the
Tysons and the Holyfields
were starting to mesh with
the Foremans and the Alis
and the Frasiers, they
did those nights together.
- [Man] Trevor Burbank
- Mm hmm, exactly.
Like that stuff.
Nobody's doing that right now,
nobody's reaching out
to Riddick Bowe or Dokes
or that era, there's some stuff
that I think could be done,
because finally there's some,
the fact that people can name
three American heavyweights,
or at least three non-eastern Europeans,
Joshua's a UK kid, the fact
that they can name you,
if they're into boxing,
the fact that you can name black guys
not just you or me or Mike.
This is a moment.
There's some underbelly shit to be done.
- [Man] Yeah its interesting cause
people today don't know
who the Beastie Boys are
they don't know people from 10 years ago.
- Cause guess what?
When you or I were 14
we didn't give a fuck
who people fucked with
in rock'n'roll either.
We're just talking old
band talk you and I now.
You don't know who the Beastie Boys are?
Of course, I'm 14
I know who lil' Xan is.
I know who Killy is do you?
They don't give a fuck.
The same way we didn't
give a fuck 20 years ago.
lil Xan fuckin' disses Tupac,
people wanna murder him.
But that's just life.
That 13 year old girl in Oklahoma
she wants to get a face tattoo.
She doesn't give a fuck about Tupac.
I know it hurts.
But guess what?
Somebody dissed on Elvis too.
(laughing)
Right?
Like what you gave a fuck
about Motown like that?
- [Man] Right, but isn't there something
those icons like Elvis for example
- There's an underlying respect.
But I promise you right now
if we go to Brooklyn right now,
they don't have the proper
respect for Smokey Robinson.
- Sure
- the end.
That's all you're talking about.
- [Man] But everything's so fragmented
you can't have that one hit thing.
And get on the today show now
and sell a million of something
- That's right, modern day PR right?
Heres what I would say
Long tail him.
You gotta train, you gotta stay focused
but whatever time's available,
and clearly if you guy are
talking Anna Kournikova
you're talking my talk.
Because now you're
thinking about it twice.
Him and I
everybody
nobody is going to effect
what's gonna happen in the
square or circle but you.
So to that point its smart to
think about Anna Kournikova
some people hear it and they're like
yo you're gonna get distracted
you didn't even get the belt yet.
Because that's gonna play it
self out one way or the other.
Exactly.
But like all the other
ancillary stuff is exactly right
if you can become culturally relevant,
its just different.
And listen, Floyd and McGregor
have shown all the kids the blueprint.
There's culture.
It's much more Hulk Hogan and Macho Man
Vince Mcmahon more than its like we think.
Meaning if you can be the biggest brand.
That really matters man.
Pernell Whitaker is all time.
But he didn't go about it that way.
- [Man] The people became the HBOs 24/7
like the lead up to the HBO fights
so Floyd was discovered by the world
when he fought De La Hoya.
- 100 percent.
- [Man] People became
emotionally attached to him
not as a boxer as a person.
- The same way that Vince
Mcmahon would show you Mr.Perfect
six Saturdays in a row
before he ever came in.
And by the time he rolled in
you were so amped
what the fuck do you think I'm doin?
What are you guys doin here?
Story telling.
So you either do it yourself
like you've been doing, I love it
but for the distribution
when you're still at where you're at
you gotta go somewhere else
the problem is everybody
thinks you need to go to
the biggest thing,
Gary Vee, Breakfast club
it all makes sense but
before you get to that
just do a bunch of little ones
I'll do little ones right now.
I was doing a little podcast yesterday
timing got broke down I was looking at it
one part of my brain was like
what the fuck are you doing this thing
that nine people are gonna listen to?
And the other part was like
this is exactly why
you're beating everybody.
While everybody's spending 80 hours
trying to figure out the plan
of how to get on the sixth things
you're just doing.
Staying active.
Right?
- Absolutely.
Just say yes.
- Yep.
- Makes sense right?
- makes sense.
- Hit up a bunch of twitch kids
and play fuckin' Ring King.
Him on right king?
Do you even know about it?
Oh you're too young.
Ring King is an NES boxing game
Mike Tyson's Punch-out is all-time.
That was the greatest fucking thing
that ever happened to me.
Nobody loved Mike Tyson more than me.
'cause I discovered him
before he went mainstream
and everybody in school
thought I was the coolest
cause he became fuckin' Mike Tyson and
I had talked about this dude Michael Tyson
cause I used to really
watch ESPN and ABC worldwide
you know?
I didn't have to wait for HBO.
Ring King was the game.
The real boxing game of Nintendo.
On twitch everybody's playing Fortnite.
And like League of Legends
and all this new shit
your cousin told you cause
Drake when on with Ninja
it finally became cultural.
But the real fuckin' jam
the real jam for authenticity
is playing old school games.
Like you fuckin' with people on Twitch
playing Ring King for Nintendo
would be viral as fuck.
And that would be your jam.
You get
okay cool you get Busta Rhymes
- [Man] You have to do that now
- It's smart right?
You love it?
- Yes
(laughing)
- And I'll do it with you first
I'm gonna set up a twitch
studio outside my office.
And you guys will come
through and we'll play
and it will go.
- I'm game.
- And it's a great game
you'll love it cause its actually
Tyson's Punch-Out you know its one person
and you're doing this way
this was literally
like you could really do shit.
I loved it cause I loved boxing so much
and like you actually
can have good strategy
its not like a bullshit game.
Like if you're better at boxing
you're better at Ring King
that the other person.
It was cool
Ring Kings the jam.
I'm about to tweet nobody
can beat me at Ring King.
See what happens.
So you see where I'm going my man?
- [Man] Yep.
- To your point
you're obviously paying attention
I remember now,
modern day PR the same
move that you've made
and why you'll win from
PR to what you're doing
which actually means something.
I'm saying go even more long tail.
- So some of the fine print you guys use
in your manual that you do
with some of your athletes?
- To be very honest
the thing we're doing right now
In the Vayner sports side
that's really winning
is honestly on some real shit.
We're building up their profiles proper
we're setting up their
Shopify stores for real.
Josh Jackson's not even in the league yet
Isaac not even in the league yet
but their fuckin' dot-dom right now
where you can buy the hoodie and the hat
this is so on point
like they're a fuckin' superstar.
So I'm kinda viggin' the game.
- [Man] And there's still
value provided for everyone.
- Correct.
- everybody wins.
- Its like the cliche thing
oh that 70 year old man with
that 20 year old hot girl.
That's a value exchange.
- totally.
- You can't judge people
for what they want in life.
Not here to judge, right?
- My main thing is you know
just make noise man in this noisy world
boxing is such a wild
west still at this point
its like in the fine-print
you get the blueprint now.
Of course your focusing on fighting
and so strict already
mentally and physically
I wanna build that foundation
- You know that works for you.
- Exactly.
That makes sense.
- Having a group of guys
that know what they're doing.
That can invest
invest in each other because of course
the more I make of
course the more you make
- Of course.
How long have you guys known each other?
- [Man] Five, six years
- Nice, long time.
How'd you guys get first connected?
- [Man] He was training at a Jiu Jitsu gym
that I was training at Hanzo Gracie's
- That fuckin' UFC that I used
to watch back in those days.
That was some different shit.
- [Man] He's a special guy Hanzo Gracie
- Very.
- [Man] Very special
but he was training for MMA
- Does he get enough respect?
- [Man] He does,
in our world he's a god.
- That's what I mean
yeah good.
- [Man] And he deserves it
because he's a real amazing human.
- That's what I know of.
From a couple people.
Yeah man listen its about
getting the right person or two
look I think you're in a sweet spot.
Heres what I know.
Inevitably there's 17 kids
running around right now outside
who really know who you are
because they love boxing
there's no other reason right?
Who understand what he
knows and what I know.
You just gotta build the right team
of people that are hungry and understand.
But I do think it's
about Instagram my guy,
I really do.
I think its a deep Instagram strategy
listen you have to show up on
those boxing highlight clips
I'm telling you its gonna work.
You don't want to be at the
mercy of who's gonna fight you
or whatever the fuckin' highlights are
you only have so many
even Mike Tyson only has so many right?
You need to be about you
and you don't need to
be calling out people
and this and that.
It needs to be about the Ring King shit,
the other interests, your opinion on
just culture right?
Like you need to social commentate.
You know like you should
document just on the phone
the first time you play twitch.
Just like everything because
people need to get to know you.
What's your favorite fruit?
What's your favorite candy?
Sour patch probably
so man people need to know
so what do we do?
Lets go right here
go to the fuckin' bodega
and fuckin' pick it up.
Honestly you don't have to
be charismatic and beautiful
you have to document.
Anna Kournikova's beautiful
all us creepers were just
looking at her pictures on the internet
that's why we liked it.
Some people are charismatic as fuck.
The Macho Man is just charismatic.
He was just charismatic right?
Some people overthink it
like I don't know what
happens when the camera
goes on you in that way.
I've seen your post-interviews
but you know what I mean?
Heres the good news it doesn't matter
the part that matters
is you love sour patch,
ya know?
That makes a connection
that's my favorite candy too.
Hashtag the candy
ya know?
I don't know if you know this,
this is crazy.
I have an indentation in my head here
a little bald spot.
My hair covers it.
But Mike Tyson had that too
I don't know if you
remember old Mike Tyson
pictures he had that little
like bald spot up here.
Like back in 86, 87.
- [Man] I thought that was like a style.
Like a slit.
- No he had the slit but
he has a little indentation
that is why I loved Mike Tyson.
- You just related to that part.
- Understand?
Want more fans?
Give them reasons to be your fan.
What's the corniest thing you love?
(laughs)
that's the fuckin question.
You know what I mean?
Do you love Madonna?
Do you like a soap-opera?
You see where I'm goin?
- Walking dead is probably
the corniest thing I like.
- You need to sit down,
watch an episode and
tweet 20 things about it
it will change your world.
Everybody's obsessed with the boxer who
punches at different angles
that we've ever seen before.
That's how I think about it.
What?
Some guys from around the way
be like "what the fuck?"
who gives a fuck.
I'll take 10 new fans
than my boys razzin' me.
Cause they're still my boys.
They're gonna find out anyway.
See where I'm goin?
You're staying in a lane
and I'm trying to expand your lane.
- (mumbling) Comic-con
when they come to your
when they do the Texas.
- And that's alright except
if you don't fuck with comic book culture
then you're just full of shit.
You know?
Like you can add your two
cents on Black Panther
cause you might say
listen, that for me as a black man
means something.
Like fuck that's crazy.
- [Man] Walking Dead
people go to Comic-Con too.
- That's true, thank you.
- I'm a huge Power Rangers fan.
- You are?
- That's my shit.
- My guy I'm tellin you
if you tweeted out like "the
blue power ranger is the one"
that will spark a whole thing.
And then this is how it works.
And you're gonna love this.
Okay maybe you put it out maybe you don't
that's the one.
Next thing you know
in two fights you come
out in a Power Ranger
fuckin outfit to the.
That's when the inside
baseball shit happens
that's when its feeding your stuff
you see where I'm goin?
And it's authentic.
You're not frontin'
- Next fight I'm comin' out
in a while Black Panther suit
the helmet, the whole nine.
The movies big so.
- But then that's you riding something.
Versus is being your own wave.
Power Rangers is big as fuck.
- Always has been.
- And always will be.
And the recall is the greatest.
Michael Dokes makes you smirk.
Got it?
The recall.
There's nobody talking about
Michael Dokes right now.
You know?
That's it.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- And listen you guys
can hit me up anytime.
Ad hoc, we can do this again.
I'm really rooting for ya champ.
I'm super excited about you man.
I was literally just
sitting in front of you
like "wow!"
Now that what's happening with
me in culture specifically,
I'm like oh okay.
You know the people you
watch documentaries of
I'm like oh I'm that guy.
You know?
And so you were just sitting here
and I was like wow if I
was just doing this in 84
that would have been Mike Tyson.
You know its cool.
That's why these
documentations gonna be fun.
You know?
- [Man] We'll get you
some tickets to the fight.
- Yeah I'll come through.
If I'm in town I will be there.
I'll be there.
(electronic dance music)